the transition for me really was when I
first became a drug addict it was so
this is something I've only kind of
realized in retrospect I mean there are
some people who who are basically kind
of a basically drug addicts because so
can in some ways kind of physically or
emotionally disequilibrium in the drug
kind of they feel is some kind of way of
stabilizing them because the model just
has too many sharp edges for me at this
kind of event of going to realize this
now is more of a kind of from is more of
a react an appropriate reaction to kind
of I've real circumstances at the time
you know I think of it probably public
like a self-made drug addict rather than
natural one so it was again it was a
serial making the wrong choices and sort
of in kind of there was a willful kind
of stupidity about you know this is you
know this is what I'm doing because I
can and to an extent and and I think you
know you get you get a kind of a meshed
in there and it becomes an if we cut
again becomes a way of the way that you
can see yourself and know your own self
image becomes kind of some ways tied up
with it
but what I found that's what I'm going
to go over that was it I don't have it
doesn't have any kind of real pull on me
it's not okay like a physical need to
have one so I kind of detoxified and
gone with the stuff and I wasn't a
physical need hard to get back into that
so that was quite interesting then but
then again I mean a kind of my
experience the drug addiction you know
it really clear it's like we have
knowing people that have been junkies
for like 30 years you know no real turn
to me and say god you're you were like
kind of six months you know a year or
whatever that's just plainer and to some
extent it is you know I think that this
up I think there's an element in our in
a kind of there's almost like a sort of
I think probably in every novelists in a
way
you know it comes out it'll be right
here I think this is an element of
wanting to sort of to try different
things in to immerse yourself in a whole
different way of life yeah so I think I
think a lot of it was to do that I
thought there is a war on jobs we this
is the biggest sort of core never I mean
it's never been a war on drugs so I
think that um I think that yummyness did
the I mean at the our site is affordable
drugs I mean the whole idea of forgive
me in the West the whole idea that we
can have from everything is a festival
everything's our event a whole advanced
culture I mean the whole idea of having
that without with without intoxication
it's just nonsense it's always been
those amove so I mean just really what
there is is an attempt to prescribe
which ways but much methods we get
intoxicated and I don't think that the
war on drugs are seriously I think that
they know that the if they if they
legalized and licensed drugs did which
kind of they would stop it straight away
they were criminal underclass and a
whole kind of all these criminal
relationships and but I mean there would
be no that would just be so much you
know there will be no kind of need for
sort of kind of law and order and I kind
of saw justice this whole kind of
security oriented society they live in
the middlee field it's like eliminates
any pretext for social control and I
think nuts for people your politicians
and so from power mongrels they don't
want no they want is very pretext for
social control as possible so I think
that they're happy to keep staging this
phony war on drugs as long as
goes on